- I did it. I finally did it.
ANDREW REID WON A SUPER BOWL!
- WOW, WHAT A FUN, EASY SPORT!
- Goodbye, Gridiron Heights.
It really means a lot to get my own farewell—
- HI, EVERYONE.
MY DAD IS STARTING X-TREME GRIDIRON HEIGHTS! LOL.
- Wait, guys—
- Eli, man, we’re on to another thing!
- I’m Oliver Luck, lol.
Because everyone's been moving recently—
- WHAT THE FLUFF IS A CHARGER ANYWAY?
- I lied to Hulu. I’ll do it. I’ll move.
- I don’t think about you as much as you think I do.
- Wait, I didn’t know I was moving.
- We now own the town.
Gridiron Heights is X-TREME now!
- OK, I’m leaving for real—OOOF.
- DO WHATEVER THE F--K YOU WANT!
- Everyone calm down. This WILL blow over.
- WHERE SHOULD I GO?!
- DERRICK, HERE!
- Yeah, but do you have enough money, though?
- TAYSOM, we need Drew!
- Should I save myself? Or is it time to give up? Hmmm…
- I’m all you need right here, sir.
- Looks like I’m in another classic Zac Taylor scrape!
- JOE BURROW!
- [Announcer:] NEXT SEASON, GRIDIRON HEIGHTS WILL COME BACK.
- [Kyle Shanahan:] NO. NO MORE COMEBACKS.
NO ONE'S EVER COMING BACK AGAIN.